gulyamov Paris Poros home lies beneath
Sicilies scorching Sun the house looks
as if it was shaped by the wind welcome
to my place follow me
the building blends into its natural
surroundings and has practically no
corners the facade is lime based plaster
a traditional building material on
Sicily the flat rounded form of the
house is influenced by traditional
Mediterranean architecture especially
that from the islands around Sicily
north of Africa in particular the
musso's Pantelleria and little islands
around Sicily some traditional Moroccan
and map and architecture from a grep
that's what inspired us
a spacious kitchen dining room is the
focal point of the 120 square meter
house colorful accessories and art
provide the only accent to this dark
point of the interior this is meant to
be the heart of the house the warmth
radiates from year on we have the Sun
coming in the chimney right behind your
shoulder the coziness of the place is
all here and all the activity is
supposed to start from here and he
radiates to the rest of the house
Tata Sporto spends several months of the
year here with his family the
furnishings are practical but well
designed a free-standing bathtub helps
residents cool in the summer even when
the mercury climbs to 40 degrees Celsius
it's still cool indoors the windows are
laid out so as to circulate cooling
breezes within the house and the thick
walls insulate from the edge as well the
walls are two actually two and one is
built perpendicular the other one is
diagonal and leave air in the middle so
they they create a space of a space of
air between the two walls which is
supposed to isolate properly we don't
even turn on the air-conditioner
actually outside an olive tree more than
a century old provides more shade the
further away you get from the house the
wilder the surroundings become a path
leads down to a pool that was
intentionally built some distance from
the house the swimming pool represents
the sea and the passage the gradual
passage down into civilization from
nature and a passage of gradual
wilderness fading until you get to the
lone which is always planned and finally
civilization the business man has
realized a childhood dream in the garden
he's built a tree house in a carob tree
a hideaway for young and old alike I
thought it was also a possibility to
isolate from the crowd from the rest of
the family and friends where you can
come here
read and even sleep and so that's why I
created I created it I decided to do it
yeah to roof terraces provide more space
for relaxation and feature an added
bonus a view of the neighboring Nature
Reserve and of the Mediterranean
[Music]
you